the state of education is pretty sorry
right now I was having a conversation
with my friend Spencer Clavin just a
couple of nights ago and
Spencer Knows a thing or two about
education he has a PHD one of one of
those with a PhD who's one of the good
ones and Spencer Clavin mentioned a clip
to me and he said Michael you have to
see this clip it is so sad but but not
sad in the way that everybody else is
saying it's sad
I think like the biggest thing that like
annoys me in like the whole dating world
is like talking stages like that's so
annoying like the whole like
and just like the inconsistency in them
like I literally like hate that like so
much but I think that's like my biggest
thing it's just like what specifically
just like the fact of just like you like
I don't know how to word this like in
like talking stages and it's just like
you're like labeled that and it's like
people like are considered like you
can't like you're just like confused and
like most of the time like the girl get
gets like attached or something and they
like see it like it's going to lead to a
relationship and it's always not and
it's just like
that's like my biggest thing is like I
just hate the whole like how like
talking stages are so like normalized
like traditional dating does not exist
in this generation
so the reason people think this is
really sad at the first layer is because
of what this young woman is describing
or at least attempting to describe which
is that women get used in this hookup
culture which now is referred to as
talking stages
like one would say euphemistically
oh we're not dating we're talking and
what are the talking stages sort of like
rounding first base second base that
would probably be the old way to talk
about it
but now there's not even a sense that
so-and-so is my girlfriend so-and-so is
my boyfriend it's just oh yeah we're
talking we're doing this we're doing
that
you know you don't really know there's
no commitment here and so she's
lamenting this and so that's sad
the somewhat deeper reason that people
are
saying that this is a very sad clip is
because the woman is not the most
articulate
so people are kind of making fun of the
woman for speaking this way I am not
making fun of her she seems like a
perfectly nice girl she's describing a
serious problem and she's doing it as
best she can and if she is a person
under the age of 50 in America
then she has had probably a pretty
crappy education and that's not her
fault if she's not totally articulate
the deepest reason though that I think
this is a really sad clip is that that
one line there where she says I don't
know how to say this I don't know how
and this woman is using the same five or
six words for the whole clip
and she's struggling there's something
that she wants to express that she can't
express because she doesn't know the
words to use to express the thing that
she is perceiving and feeling
that's what sir said and it's it's an
issue that I talk about all the time
it's the point of my book speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
which is available there we are we have
it
if you can't articulate a problem
you can't solve the problem
language
establishes the limits and Contours of
our thought of our consciousness of the
way that we perceive and conceive of the
world
not just what we think but what we even
can think I'll give you a great example
of this that I was thinking about just
the other day in the Italian language
there is no word in Italian for privacy
when Italians talk about privacy they
just say la privacy
they use the English word which tells
you a lot about the Italian culture
tells you something serious about the
Italian culture which is that Italians
don't value privacy in any way and never
have
so if they're going to refer to this
concept they refer to it as a foreign
concept and they use a foreign word if
your culture doesn't have a word for
privacy then your culture is not going
to have privacy
the fact that the Liberals control our
language they do their best to shape our
language and make us use stupid pronouns
and tell us we can't say all sorts of
words the reason they do this is not
just because they're scolds the reason
they do this is not because they're
neopuritans necessary not entirely at
least the reason they do this is because
they know that if they take certain
words out of our vocabulary and they
twist the meaning of other words it's
going to completely warp the way that we
view the world we won't even be able to
express our dissatisfaction and our
objections to the things that they are
doing the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member and use code Knowles can a wlas a
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
thank you